[Music]
boy this is the guy want to have on
certainly after what happened last night
for the best picture announcement Kevin
Frazier from Entertainment Tonight
joining us where were you when that
announcement was made Kevin dance so
this is from my Forge days that I always
leave the venue when the show is
starting to watch on TV and that's what
we all used to do you know and whether
it be an NBA Finals forever and before
they started installing televisions in
the arena so we write we have a hotel
next door so you go next door to watch
the Oscars and you can sit in the hotel
you can watch the Oscars while
everything goes down and I mean look
let's just get to the nuts and bolts of
this deal okay here's what happened
Price Waterhouse in Cooper's has
duplicate of every single envelope so
there's two right Warren comes out from
the other side and he has a duplicate of
the envelope for um actress in a leading
role he walks out with it it has been
photographed it's now been it's
understood that that sweetie and he had
the duplicate of the category before he
gets out there he opens that envelope
and he's like rut wrong there's a big
prop now who gives him the envelope so
Price Waterhouse Coopers handles the
envelope they hold the envelopes
sometimes there is a stage manager in
between them we don't know who that
person was who actually put it in his
hand but Price Waterhouse in Cooper's
holds the envelopes until it is time for
you to go out then they will transfer
the envelope and it will get into the
hands of the person who goes out on
stage now there are two things no one
looked at the envelope to see that the
raw it was clearly the wrong category
and then once they got out there and
they realized there was a mistake I
think that Warren was trying to show
freak dunaway to say yeah I think this
is wrong but Faye Dunaway just saw a lot
of land with Warren saw the Emma Stone
lot of land on there and that's where
the confusion happened ed you see the
people from Price Waterhouse but meeting
Lee come out on stage to try and correct
it because they
no it's wrong because they know every
single one of the winners and losers
beforehand and they're committed to
memory the LA Times had a great picture
of this is where everybody is looking up
you it's a picture of all of the people
in the audience and you just see their
mouths are open as if to say oh my god
what just happened is there a this
wasn't part of any any skit with jimmy
kimmel because that was it because
that's twitter started with that and I
said boy I can pull off a good hoax but
even Hollywood couldn't do this no not
this this was not a hoax and if you have
any question go back to a shot and we'll
have it on the show to that where you
see the faces of the people from the
accounting firm because they are
freaking out here's the thing they've
been doing this for 80 years there has
been and people are saying this has
never happened before there was a near
mistake with Sammy Davis back in 1964
but he was doing a music category and
the folks realized he had the wrong
envelope and rushed out and gave him the
right envelope but this time it actually
got announced and the people walked out
there but you look at the people's face
no my gosh and then Selma Hayek who's
backstage she was right there and she
said she could hear over the headset of
one of the stage managers people yelling
he's got the wrong envelope he has the
wrong envelope the wrong envelope it's
the wrong envelope anybody talked to
Warren Beatty after um yeah a lot more
and talk to lots of folks and he he did
say you know he went out to parties and
you know what he said look he wanted to
hold on to the envelope and make it
right and that he saw he was confused
because it said Emma Stone lalala and
that it makes sense and i think the real
mistake is when he turned and showed it
to fay fay just saw a la la land and
blurted it out and i think he was
turning to her to say this might be
wrong and so it seemed like he was
playing coy and she was caught up in
maybe the moment of him playing coy and
that's why she said la la land and from
there i mean the nightmare began that
and you could see it on his look at
watch warrant face even when she says
ronalyn like all boy
iiiiii what we were aiming to do did you
go to la la land or moonlight after
party did they have separate doll ok no
because we thought we talked to all
those folks afterwards I mean everybody
from in the back and the press room to
the Governor's Ball we talked to
everybody and the folks for moonlight
were confused the folks from lala land
were confused and it was the one
producer who stepped forward he said he
knew was wrong and he heard everybody
walking around saying this is wrong this
is wrong this is wrong wyndham when the
stage managers came out that's when the
people on stage realized what was wrong
and understand this people had gotten up
ready to go people are ready to leave
you know they're giving a standing
ovation this is the last war tonight you
have to get to the Governor's Ball which
is upstairs and then after the
Governor's Ball then you go to the party
so it's a really long night and it's
late because even though it's earlier on
the west coast by the time you go and
shake hands in the Governor's Ball do
press in the building and all that stuff
and then you leave and go out to your
parties i mean you're talking about a
night where you're hitting parties at 11
and you're not going home till two three
o'clock so it was people wanted to get
out and they always do and so that's
where you know there's that anxiousness
and then everyone's like are you kidding
me he's Kevin Lampinen work were blown
away they were just standing there like
what you're happened he's Kevin Frazier
from Entertainment Tonight joining us
was this a great moment or a horrible
moment for the Academy word I think it
was a horrible moment for price Cooper's
Waterhouse are I'm pronouncing wrong but
anyway it was it was a bad night for the
accounting firm it was still a moment
that everyone is talking about as far as
the Academy Awards go and it was a great
show otherwise so I think the Academy
Awards listen they go on they'll be okay
and whoever's going to take that fall
whether it be a stage manager or the
accounting firm somebody's gonna take
that that fall but it was a great night
for the Academy there were enough great
moments that people will move forward
this is what they need to do they need
to say to Warren Beatty and Faye Dunaway
we want you back next year to one
hundred percent right just like Steve
Harvey came back and did the Miss
Universal or if you're
Steve re made a big flub but now his was
because there were two names actually on
the card but he came right back to next
year they joked about it they made fun
of it it was fun and he got it right in
the end and that's what you have to do
and people will tune in just to see them
come back people will be waiting for
that I was I would have them back I'd
have Kimmel back I do though listen it
was a great night and I would have all
those folks back who's still on partying
oh wow there's it what it all depends I
will say this there's some folks for
moonlighter her still party the young
especially the younger guys for
moonlight who are on we're on a hype
already and so they are so loud party I
want to believe that Emma Stone hasn't
gone home yet and here's the thing
damage you don't you got to understand
people who win so say you win as a sound
engineer right you take your Oscar and
you walk around and you go to every
single party with your Oscar because it
gets you in any and every party so there
are the there's the Governor's Ball and
then after that the party that you have
to go to because of your movie company
then there are the late night parties
that you really want to get into and as
long as you short with that Oscar you
can get in you can have a posse of 10
your it can be bigger than an MBA posse
but you can get in because you have an
Oscar and then there's also the people
who party then they go out and have a
little in and out do they go and drink
somewhere hands oh it's you know it can
be a long night because here's the thing
most folks they don't have to be on set
tomorrow so they can go hard they can go
really hard I mean this is your one
night go crazy I'll tell you who is one
of the MVPs last night Janelle Monae let
me tell you how beautiful her dress
looked big I'm out and about but in
pictures and stuff but I mean up close
she literally took your breath away her
and priyanka chopra's dress up I mean
look when I saw the two of them I was
vote with both of those I you're like
whoa world world world world world world
because you don't listen and let's be
honest you react as a man when you're
out there you know everybody's like oh
the fashion the fashion know your first
reaction is as a guy and you look over
your like there is a crazy beautiful
woman in a dress that looks
so hot it is amazing and we always have
this fun thing we do on the red carpet r
you were like the hottest nons are the
best-looking best-dressed non-star
whether it's you know someone who is
nominating the lesser category or it's
you know someone's date or wife or son
who has the best dressed and that you
know that that is fun early on to check
that out too always great talking to kev
get some sleep and tonight with nancy
o'dell and entertainment tonight at
seven thirty eastern on my TV set but
kev thanks for joining us yeah thanks
for having me alright talk to you guys
soon all right Kevin Frazier nobody
breaks down the Academy Awards look
quite like he's the Mel Kiper of Academy
Awards there the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]